[Applaudissements]
c'est parti qu'est ce que vous pensez
transports en commun de parisiens
heureusement qu'ils sont là je me
déplace qu'avec eux et votre n en pense
quoi
on s'est tous dit bah oui ok i'm your
sister est bon maintenant ça va parce
que je suis enceinte et qu'on me laisse
la place mais autrement c'est un peu
leur art et votre soeur n'en pensent
quoi épuiser épuisant ne laisse jamais
la place on est usé à l'image qu'on 34
ans et loire mais c'est un fait on est
solidaires ils sont poussés plutôt pas
mal desservies après c'est dommage parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de travaux donc pour
les étudiants qui habitent loin c'est
plutôt chiant et votre frère il en pense
quoi
ra la cafetière ou pas j'ai une plus
belle moustache que toi mon gars j'avoue
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens
je trouve qu'il ya pas mal de problèmes
et quand tu as des problèmes c'est
vraiment infernal et votre famille elle
en pense quoi
d'accord d'accord à 100%
d'accord d'accord et bien d'eric voilà
il continue ses aventures c'est un des
rites de plus du sud de l'allemagne
et alors aujourd'hui d'un proche il veut
changer de voiture il a un truc il a
flashé sur un truc